Một ngày 1,5 năm, ngày 29, tông tin từ công an thành phố Hàn Nội, đơn vị vừa bắt đợi tự trinh á phà Thí Lệ,
sinh 1,5,5,5, chú xá bằng lần tình phụ thọ.
Theo hồ sơ, nghen 1 năm, tháng 12,5 năm, các quan cạnh rất đợi trà công an thành phố Hàn Nội ra
cứ định hợi tổ bị cán đối với phà Thí Lệ về tự cưỡa tài xà.
Thuy nhiên, lưỡi tự đá bỏ trữ khỏi nơi cơ chú.
Nên 1,5 năm, ngày 29,5 năm, các quan cạnh rất đợi trà công an thành phố phố Hàn Nội đã ra
tự trà công an thành phố Hàn Nội đang lần chú trong 1 quan cơ đầu kỳ trên địa bản xà bà chế.
Tình còn ninh, dưới vào bọc là ninh viên, ngày 29,5 năm, ngày 29,5 năm, tông công
tắc của bàn phòng các quan cạnh rất đợi trà công an thành phố Hàn Nội đã bắt sữ thành công đợi tự.
Hình có quan cạnh rất đợi trà công an thành phố Hàn Nội đang đợi trà, dưới tự thọc vi đi.